my name is Carlos Portola but you know
the drunk community I'm known as Chapel
we want to get into this kind of hobby
you know the first thing I tell
everybody is start small learning the
controls of one of these quads it's
actually pretty complicated I always
recommend getting a little one you know
a toy they have a lot of them online for
under $100 it gets you to understand how
one of these little things fly and then
from there you can slowly build up it's
gonna take a little bit of time to get
used to it you know your brain have to
kind of like rewire to understand how
these things move some people take a few
days so the people take a few a few
weeks you know but eventually is gonna
get that you're going to start to feel
that freedom
I think every time you come to a new
location and especially something like
this is to just get really excited
first thing is walking around making
sure that there's nobody around that I'm
it's a safe place and then maybe turning
on your drone and flying around a little
bit and making sure that your video
frequencies working correctly you're not
going you're not getting any
interference I definitely recommend
building your own why because if you
build it you're gonna know how to fix it
and when you get into this hub you're
gonna be breaking a lot of stuff so
you're gonna have to fix it so basically
the way you fly one of these things is
like it so we stilted forward you know
so that's why the camera is always a
little bit tilted up so when you're
moving forward you can keep the horizon
in the right place basically these runs
are so agile you can really depending of
the angle you're tilting forward the
speed is faster or slower you can also
easily roll basically you have a
complete freedom of all three axes at
the moment you are used to controlling
it it feels like an out-of-body
experience and it almost feels like
you're inside a complete different like
animal